you ever try to sing a song when you
can't hit that note and just pisses you
off you know me now you want to die no
anyway your [ __ ] oh
what is going on YouTube I keep on using
my hand you but recently I read any
comments where a subscriber told me that
I am very negative well go yourself
well because you asked you're not to
listen I'm gonna blog about something
that I like which is very hard for me
because you know personally I'm that new
that will love you but when you're
successful on the side I wish the worst
upon you David I won a million dollars
congratulations hope you catch the
plague you punk [ __ ] baby thanks man I
appreciate wait what was it huh what not
said I hope you catch some rays you
uh-huh I hate you honey
so let's talk about something I like you
know what I like I like McDonald's you
know what okay I don't like this [ __ ] I
love that [ __ ] and I don't know why
bossed me look I know what you're gonna
say did you see that documentary Super
Size Me for shame
dance that question yes I did and is it
weird that after watching this [ __ ] it
made me hungry
lesbian without did you see that Big Mac
in that documentary how come my Big Mac
never looked like that
and of course you're going to ask did
you know McDonald's has this amount of
calories look I'll be honest with you
I'll try to be more fish I don't know
what other calorie is you know what our
ease off flavor points [ __ ] deal with
it that's right the bigger the number
the better it tastes throw - I love with
McDonald's I love the filet-o-fish
here's a general advice you should
probably not buy seafood from a
fast-food restaurant but I don't give a
[ __ ] it's delicious you know what the
secret ingredient is and that brand is
crack I found out that's right I was all
homeless dude jump in the middle of
street stop a car with his bare hands
just to grab a flail fish that's right
that's a crack induced action you know I
gotta talk about the chicken make mother
[ __ ] Nuggets move and yes I can see
that
our goal we're chicken nuggets was being
squeezed out of a tube and it looked
like a pink and purple paste when I saw
those chicken others being squeezed out
of that tube tell me how I'm the only
one that pulled the Dave Chappelle I
said I'm Dan Purple's I love McDonald's
breakfast sausage Egg McMuffin with the
hash brown and an orange juice you know
every time you see a sausage egg and an
English muffin you call it a Miss
nothing and it's not called ëthe that's
the power of McDonald's baby you know
what it's really about
it's about that hash brown no matter
where you go nothing tastes like a
McDonald's hash brown Oh Junior Burger
King checking the box stop kill yourself
what get a free ad campaign what would
you do for McDonald's hash brown ah some
delicious soda and eat it with the hash
browns that's what I said
oh and here's another thing everyone out
there on a healthy tip ah
get that thing [ __ ] like uh you know
that stuff's bad for you right huh yeah
you know what else bad for you tell me
nothing McDonald [ __ ] up cajeta saying
that is useless because nobody goes to a
McDonald's for a healthy ass veal and if
you do you might be a grown-ass man with
some zico titties ah mr. McDonald's is
that your name is that right and you're
out there you watching this video I know
you try to be all family-friendly [ __ ]
I'll tell you right now that's the wrong
way to do it you think decent family's
body boom hell no yo [ __ ] is unhealthy
as bad be real ghetto ass people with
speech impediment buy that [ __ ] let me
be the face of victims that's right
Linda same way that's not a pet
[ __ ] grimace the hamburger and Ronald
McDonald what you need is a new
character the the Korean burger monster
head [ __ ] each of mine he will be all
of your pinch pride sound like a Korean
vampire what is going on YouTube I have
some exciting news for y'all one of my
personal favorite comedians Pete Holmes
is coming out with a brand new
late-night series starting on October
28th what is the show called you ass is
called a Pete Home Show and trust me
it's gonna be dope and of course the
show is produced by Kona Co the company
behind the late-night hit coming you
know me I showed you love me some coke
mmm that sounds inappropriate the series
will air Monday through Thursday
at midnight following Conan on TBS one
of my personal favorite sketches that
Pete does is when he dresses up as an
[ __ ] doctor and comes up with some of
the most ridiculous situations if you
guys want to check one out check out
doctor symptoms and you guys will know
what I'm talking about
in all honesty Pete is an amazing
comedian and overall he's just an
amazing guy to me comedy has always been
a healing art form and meeting Pete I
think he really understand that mindset
so once again make sure you guys check
it out on October 28th on TBS and make
sure you guys support the homie and let
me know what you think about it cause
I'll be watching it with y'all - that's
something that I like which is very
difficult different of our civility
should probably not buy see proof of a
fat seafood what the [ __ ] is see fruit
probably not buy seafood from a fast
food restaurant flip that around I'll
say that 10 times fast seafood from a
fat man with it you know every time you
see a sausage which is just end the
sentence with that you know every time
you see a sausage fill in the blank